all right this should be interesting
hopefully for future Arenas they'll be
there'll be more in there but still a
lot of
players are not aware of this variant
a group of ten
spinal tap
International master
all right so this is going to be three
two 55 minutes of capablanca
chess
we'll see how this goes it'll be my
first time playing against
a human
all right good luck
those of you competing
don't hurt me too bad
all right
let me just make sure
board setting I'm zoomed in as best I
can alright let's get this first move in
hopefully there's not too many
not too many glitches so I'm already
threatening
this Pawn may be I don't know if I want
to take them
okay
mm-hmm
we'll go with this
you know I I like I like playing these
positions where I have the potential to
exchange off
the Bishops
these are the ones oh really
I used to see that
I'm gonna go with this one too
see when when I was playing in the early
going with this variant I was moving
these Center pawns and trying to deploy
the Bishops like that
but these diagonals can really turn out
to be effective
and let's get this one in here I want a
square for this Knight
wow that's a big move so there's a
weakness on this Square
um
I feel like I want to take another step
here
I'm gonna go with that and then try and
exchange dark light Square Bishops
this is how I played it in the in the
video I have currently on YouTube
recognizing good bad Bishops
okay so this is under control the
Archbishop
um
yeah let's get let's go for this right
now
let's do it now
could go here
okay that one so this is the offer of
the
the Archbishop
okay I have to be careful
I don't know that this is correct though
I think I just want to challenge it
so all these squares under control
by my my Bishop here my Archbishop
you want to go here
to watch out this guy's so dangerous
hmm
Chop Chop okay
all right it's almost regular chess
all right let's maneuver
I have the better Bishop
oh
all right I'll initiate the exchange
and now I can feel a little bit more
comfortable now that things have
simplified
a little bit more comfortable moving
this Chancellor out
the night Rook combo
on top in
you know what I could play this and then
play here
now let's go in right away
I'm attacking this it's defended with
this guy
um
okay
let's go here
preparing to Castle I want to keep this
defended though
oh wait why can't oh I play here that's
right I think his fish are random
okay let's control this night jump
down on the clock
oh I was thinking for a second I have a
fork
not quite
this feels a bit slow
am I in trouble already
could be in trouble
this night is much better than mine
I want to get rid of it
need a couple more moves for me to feel
comfortable
Maybe
not have much time
it's a very good player could tell
I'm gonna challenge this guy
oh wait it's like
that Bishop almost trapped
I'm almost gonna get mated
Brook activity
okay it's regular chess
I have a wild Rook
okay let's swipe upon
and now get behind this guy
I should be winning
I want to get this Square
they could have two very outside passers
now this guy's running fast
let's kick that King away first and then
get behind the pawn
I'm hiding from the checks
this one's not easy to track
yeah I'm pushing through
I'll go with the chancellor try to work
with the
a new piece
all right they resigned back to
tournament
what are the standings we got 16 in
there whoa I didn't have any time to
have any time to even check out the
standings okay oh I got an 1801 rating
okay
let's go with this again
bear a barracuda
okay
I offer you an exchange
I should hang on
taking with the pawn or the Archbishop I
don't know
let's take with the pawn
still keep this guy around
because now this guy is kind of saying I
dare you a castle Queen side and this
one is saying I have an eye on you if
you Castle kingside
okay
uh huh
ideally I want my pawns on dark squares
I think
that's still a good idea
um probably a good idea to open up this
guy's eyes and also a square for my
knight
this Square I don't have to watch over
as much because this guy is in the way
so even when this guy moves this isn't a
threat okay so this could be nearby
um
setting that one up maybe
if I could do that seems really slow
let's try it
this push and then take
I'm assuming this is the idea
also now that I don't have the dark
Square Bishop so I have to be careful to
you know this this Chancellor getting
here
I want to be able to meet it with this
but now this guy is here so that's not
going to be easy
okay I think I want to take
uh this guy is up for grabs isn't he
[Music]
um
maybe I don't like that idea after all
pushing that Palm
all right let's try and hang on to him
put this Knight here
I haven't moved a single thing on my
king side
okay
I could challenge that guy
it's night's in the way taking towards
the center these guys are already
developed I like it
my Knights need to play
so it's the archbishops
be very careful
that seems healthy
so where are you going King
the old-fashioned Rooks might get you
whoa
there might already be something
dangerous happening
this guy
this guy could be a killer
okay don't don't get
too excited yet let's let's put this guy
here
I should have played this this was
better
all right it's yeah I I should be
playing this so maybe that maybe maybe
this
although I'm expecting it to get shut
down I feel like I should have an attack
it could happen really fast
okay step one
Queen has a square so this and then here
there could be something brutal
happening okay my Archbishop has been
shut out
or you would think
but I could get on a new diagonal I also
have a square here
let me hop to it
jump to that newly weakened Square I
have the better Bishop
a secure night not easily challenged
taming this guy
if this guy moves my queen I think wants
to bolt right in
that one
okay
I feel like I wanna
feel like I wanna want
there's pressure here
I feel like I want to ignore any of this
stuff
let's do this
I wanna I wanna
do something as G2
this is sensitive
is that what you're going after
all right let's try and remove this
defender or at least allow my queen to
be invited into the
kingside
oh boy
um
that's a good move
all right I don't like doing this with
my Rook I I feel like I should have
captured this these there's some
sacrifice
Happening Here If I Had defended Bishop
takes Queen takes
not ideal
I have to undo stuff
game continues 11 seconds
oh wait a second this guy here the
weaknesses of the dark squares
get this guy right here
the Archbishop
is ready to rumble I think
this can maybe be a move I could take
him if I need to
that guy's pinned
it's not defended
so now there's some dangerous stuff
happening
some dangerous stuff
is that working
check and I win the queen
who
now the Queen's defended I want
something else I'm on this night what a
fork
guy's a wizard
that Archbishop
he's a wizard
get back over Rook you don't have to
defend here anymore
um here
uh
I had to give him up oh no
my time
oh boy
check
discover check
got the Archbishop
and I should be getting mate two
different mates
not quite
Bishop here
okay should have it
Gotta Give up the clean
they resigned back to tournament oh what
a wild game wow the pairings are fast
I don't even know where I'm at
whoo okay let's go let's start with D3
spider
I don't know what position I'm in either
it doesn't show that
E3 and E4 what's that move about oh if
ready to fiend Kettle the arch the Arch
Bishop
is that the plan
all right let's put another Pawn in the
center
take some space
develop a night
all right let's see how they react to
this now that
this guy isn't here
can't easily offset the chancellor
although I don't know if I'm ready to
even take
from being a honest about it
because this and then here
and I think I lose my Chancellor
that's how it works out I don't have
this
so it's a bit of a poison Pawn
let's develop though
Bishop E3 seems healthy so I I've just
formed a battery
oh light square or dark Square
weaknesses so what about this
now this is almost Gonna Be Me
it's a mate threat Bishop takes Pawn
takes Archbishop to H6 game over
that'd be made
it's a killer peace
they missed it
it's me
if it's captured it's mate
game over nine mover back to tournament
where are we at I mean second I got
eight I have fire there's only 34
minutes left
okay
that is a dangerous piece it is a weird
looking mate isn't it
what a monster
I was I was defeated okay I won that in
nine moves but
uh I got mated in seven moves
against the stockfish did I am I in
pause
no it's just waiting to pair me here
everybody's in the game
all right nice to see 17 players
three games in
yeah I'm not in pause mode
a couple others in pause mode
all right we'll wait it out
yeah so I haven't with how my opponent
started that last game
the the idea to feed Kettle the
Archbishop that isn't that isn't an idea
I've seen before
by the engine I'm not saying it's bad
it's just I haven't seen it before
still a lot of
there's a lot of stuff I haven't seen
okay here we go
and go for this again
an immediate question to the dark Square
Bishop
hmm another
another fiend Keto
interesting okay let's develop this
Knight
the Arch Bishop
oh okay so hmm that move
makes me think
I should have exchanged dark Square
Bishops when I had the chance
[Music]
okay I feel like I could be in trouble
now
because what in the world is this guy
doing over here
it's not stopping the Chancellor from
getting to i3
I think this could be really painful
there let's try and tame this guy
somewhat
okay
Bishop there and
maybe I could
let's try
let's try this
Bishop F7
Chancellor G3
it sounds so weird
uh
what if I go here
where's this guy going
then you have to go back
ah back you go
all right let's try this
big fan of trading these uh Bishops as
soon as possible
you'll notice
boom boom boom
okay let's go back
kicking the Knight back they're freeing
up the this guy to move
I like this move to not only tame this
guy but also this one
there
I guess I'll initiate the exchange
and maybe offer a chancellor
um
I'll have to worry about this jump it's
looking dangerous
huh
they're connected on this point
hmm
it's like an F5 Square in regular chess
I guess
I guess this one's all right to play
you got this guy around
I am coordinated on G4
this guy's so stupid so is this one
what are you even doing
controlling this
this guy pretty well
a break oh a dark Square Bishop exchange
I'm gonna go for it now because this
demotes the Knight
and then
then maybe take
there's going to be an accident
Happening Here that's gonna that's gonna
hurt me
let's let that sit let's develop this
guy
no light Square Bishop to bother queen
queen takes Chancellor could be a move
okay so we have an interesting imbalance
uh it's the queen versus Chancellor in
bounds
recapture I have a check in the position
the night has arrived
you ready to take that guy aren't you
aren't you
I could push
and then play here and defend
to watch out for a sacrifice here this
would be
brutal
also I have this covered
okay I guess I'm losing a pun unless I
want to play this move
hmm okay if I play this Chop Chop
there's a check I don't like that I
think we're gonna play it where I just
have to give up that pawn
wow okay let's go here
let's keep this guy around since the
king is on this wing
they didn't go for this Pawn so
are these ideas
maybe this
I feel like I could quickly attack with
everything but this night
do I even need to go anywhere with my
king
can I just leave him here
let's develop the queen I think I still
want a castle actually
Castle I'm defending my furthest
Advanced Pawn
and bring this Rook up and over
don't forget he moves like a knight
drift over here
so a lot of attention on this point I do
not this is such a short time control
I think I wanna
play here get this guy
working
guessing he's gonna be
challenged soon feels healthy to go here
I'm not in a pin or anything but
take
fall back
I have pressure here
can't let me have a
about this
should be better here
oh they missed that it was defended
I'm ready to take here we'll have a
Archbishop versus Chancellor in bounce
let's try that
this guy
is going to try and be a beast
this is this is looking really serious
threatening the or not quite threatening
The Rook but
this here
there should be mate soon
check
check
and then we have a bit of a smothered
mate going on next
oh
okay back to tournament land
and another fast pairing how much time
is remaining
I don't know
all right let's stick with D3
Cube stack
let's do it
so I learned a little something there I
should have I should have initiated the
exchange that idea to
to prevent me from exchanging dark
Square Bishops
I think that was wise
in my my Bishop looks so foolish over
here
so let's see
these checks can maybe hit okay there's
there isn't that anymore
let's put this guy in the center
two diagonals three diagonals I've seen
some some tricks where the queen goes
right in here
this this is a really sensitive spot
this looks Wild
I4
the the G5 the G4 of regular chess
and my first thought was to tame that
guy but he's already Tamed
um
maybe G maybe the real G4
no I I don't like blocking that light
score Bishop maybe maybe I played in the
same way
this bit this seems healthy
Bishop on E3
so easy to miss something
these guys are so valuable
but you know if you bring them out too
early just like in regular chess you
bring that Queen out early they get
harassed with the miners
okay where's this guy headed
here maybe
let me cut out a square
control the Knight control the bishop
sum
Maybe
like a question this night
what's that move
you know what I don't want to see him go
any further there might be
some
some nice positive and having access to
that A5 square with the Rook
some King side attack one day he travels
quite a ways but that might be in the
air
all right what's this guy up to
probably needs to drift towards the king
side
he's really flexible from this point
okay that weakens the light squares
I don't know if I could take advantage
of that though
and I want to put this Knight here
blocking this guy
playing here there's that
okay maybe we initiate some
complications
maybe I feel okay putting this guy here
supporting this Advance maybe I could go
for this or this and then this
this crossed my mind before making this
move
so right now this guy could go here here
there there there
isn't good this is probably
gonna get kicked
maybe ask that guy a question
recapture
no light Square Bishop I feel much more
comfortable putting these guys
on light squares
okay
fancy
let's put this guy here developing
behind my my pawns I'm staying fluid
these still have
they still have options
hang on yeah I I wanna I wanna recapture
with this so I could have a a triple
battery
along a diagonal that's that's not
so common
you also have a quadruple of somebody
called it a bazooka
like four
the chancellor the queen in both Rooks
all in one file
so I'm threatening to chop away on this
square and I have to take away from the
center
they could probably do something on this
light Square
or I would look to try and do something
on that light Square
ideally I want pawns on light
so this one's still under control
I could also step up here
seems to be
secure on this F3 Square
it's the first time I'm actually ahead
on the clock
got a mover
let's get that one in
kingside Castle I don't know if the
king's any safer if you go there
these moves this move it might almost be
mate
okay
let's go with this one
we're looking to break now
it's covered
multiple times
okay this guy
can challenge it
kick it right back actually
and let's do that go back home get out
of here
get out of here
I think I'm comfortable with castling
ready to open up the center now
okay I didn't see that one coming
Let's Fall Back secure my Center points
still take with a pawn
same story
challenge
challenge
not easy it goes here
okay could I not take advantage of that
PIN
to the chancellor
files opening up
not yet castled
I got the chancellor
I have a check
in this Square
also take the Knight this should almost
certainly be winning oh wait a second I
can move with discover check this guy
Archbishop
has landed
maybe something even better
all right let's let's camp out here
triple trouble
clean and shop now
foreign
I got some wild pieces here
should be made soon
probably missed some mates
right here for me
covered
okay back to tournament Where Do We
Stand I'm in second 16 spinal is
Flawless spinal's the opponent okay
don't hurt me man
ah quick Striker
all right I'm gonna go with this guy
oh boy
alrighty
there's some quick opening trap
am I gonna get killed
let's go with this one
um
now let's go with
all right let's go to
Queen check I have that covered
I'm not I'm staying uncommitted with my
dark Square Bishop for a moment
it's my
uh small pond Center
playing like a computer this is what the
computer plays
okay
I don't want to invite this guy out
scaring me
okay I do want to support my Center
though
let's go here
I think that's okay
I've seen the computer Chop Chop give a
check
exchange Bishops then there
let's see what he comes up with
Bishop out and about
you're lining up some saccharoni
possibly
no I have I have a lot of support there
I don't know if that would be wonderful
hmm
c6d6
H6 G6
kg
both under two
all right
what is he thinking of
there's so much variety
still
oh it's playing like a computer
that's what the engine does
you're more experienced
I know that I want to allow that pawn to
go any further
I don't know if I have much choice
though hey push
I guess I could push
my light squares though
okay hopefully I'm able to take care of
my light squares
so this Knight is under control although
I've seen some crazy sacrifices playing
the engine where he still just Dives in
some minor piece sacrifices quite common
in this variant what's that move about
hmm
it's the story with that one
somewhat baffled by that move
huh
the Archbishop
you wanna
you wanna play with that imbalance
spinal
is that you wanna I'll let you go for
that you want my Chancellor
come on
Chancellor for Archbishop the standoff
you could take me but I can't take you
okay here we go this guy is better
but I'm gonna try and
do something dangerous with this guy
we're gonna see
we're gonna try to do something
dangerous
um behind development
okay
yikes
uh need to move my knight is hanging on
he could fall
Queen there
probably need to just go
back
I think I want to Castle Queen side oh
that's where you're going
yep
I understand
all right let's go here
and see if you're scared
here comes the Archbishop
I only have 21 seconds
are you scared
you can exchange them play regular chess
I want a castle you're gonna let me
Castle
oh
here
I think there was an ID with a fork and
then this
this night's stupid
oh
now they're in balance
[Laughter]
watch out this guy's dangerous don't
give me this Square you might get hurt
okay
back I go
I should have played here what am I
doing
this guy's ready to rumble
that guy's gonna be dangerous both
continue to live off of the increment
okay it's regular chess
get out of there
not a fun move to play
oh nice move
you got me man
you got me
or do you could I you have a lot of past
puns over here but are you over
committed
I can't let that happen come on I need
to keep the Queens on
what are you doing
this Pond scaring you
are you scared yet
what about now
do I have anything can I work with that
pawn
it should not work
I have another angle
oh he missed that one whoo
my queen was slick
he was my queen was slick
[Laughter]
oh you get juked you might have got
juked there I was only I was only
looking at this this diagonal I was like
wait a second I have another one
this board stretches your mind let me
tell you
hey I better make a move you dummy
wow okay this is gonna be the last Game
Cube stack again
there's our match score
okay
let's start with this one or no this one
here
I guess
no great checks
no Chancellor this Square
okay
in the night
the night is out and about
all right let's put a pawn in the center
both my Bishops
covering a lot of ground
okay dark Square Bishop Exchange
noted
okay let's bring a night out
I'm ready to recapture with the queen
okay
what's that move about I wonder oh
stopping maybe a night jump
Maybe
let's go here
hinting at this
do I want to take with the queen
maybe there's a maneuver
with my knight to E6
doesn't give a preview when you hover
over
okay
oh so
that stopped but now I don't have to
worry about
like this this is an option all of a
sudden
maybe maybe I put another Pawn in the
center then
open up this guy's eyes
this might be a little too on the
passive side
but another thing is if you're if you're
maybe try and take over too many squares
you leave a lot of gaps behind and
I don't know
it's tough to judge the 10 by 8 in these
two wild
these two new wild pieces
Bishop there
okay I think I want to cut out a square
this could be a sensitive point I'm
expecting these guys will be gone and
this would be unprotected so
also it paves the way for the the
Archbishop to be deployed on this dark
Square I could maybe already start
thinking about going to a dark Square
and feeling comfortable
oh
clean there so I could play Chancellor
out
yeah I'll go with that we'll see if we
get this in bounce
Queen for Chancellor
this is defended
definitely taking towards the center
okay I have a file
this Pawn is pinned
this guy is out I want to tame it
the best way to tame it is with the
Archbishop
I'm also developing this is a
comfortable Square I like my position
healthy play in the center
and sure what that's about exactly
maybe exchange and step up with the
clean
let's go for that one
threatening to win
I could push this Knight around
okay it's defended
probably on a queen side Castle
or maybe push here first
you know let's start some
some attack
now that I could Castle on either side
or not at all
I think I want to have this position
open up so
both hit with the tempo do I want the
tempo against the Knight or this Pawn
I think I want to kick this Knight away
from a
well where does it even go
has to go back I'm gonna go with the
um
let me see Knight or Pawn
yeah I think removing this Knight
even yeah even if you could manage to
Castle
because there could be a big attack
nearby I think I want to go here now
where's that night going
foreign
on one square
I think I'm going to go for it
I also play here I gotta go fast
we have 14 seconds term is probably over
okay wait Rook up and over
oh wait there's got to be some sacrifice
here
just realizing I have a battery
that's mate if they take the Rook
Archbishop strikes
absolute killer
I could go back threatening this and
mate
this is this is definitely winning
okay let's take here
then here
is cutting out this Square
all right they're down on time
back to tournament I think that's it yes
it is complete
all right good games all this was fun
uh uh how many games six games three
plus two 21 players for first
capablanca Arena that I've held at least
I appreciate you guys all coming out to
play this
uh variant
it's uh very interesting one
okay very nice